Hóa Sí Trung Quốc chưa sẽ hành trình được chỉ uống thư chức trang sẽ đạn cuối ở 2 mi tư.
Trong một video đang hôm mấy bẩy tháng 1 một,
Kha Phi, Hóa Sí có hơn 2 phải sáo trụ người hâm mộ trên đu zin
cho biết được trên đoán mắt bệ uống thư chức trang sẽ đạn cuối cách đây sau tháng.
Cô đã trải qua chính đợt hoa chỉ như suhoi không cải thiện và ngày càng đau đốn.
Trong đợt hoa chỉ cuối cùng, tôi linh tục suy vào trạm Thai Homemê,
sau đó tình dậy gạo thế vị quá đau đốn, của nói.
Chứ đó, hồi tháng 6, Kha Phi tư lộ của mắt bệ uống thư chức trang yếu gặp xó khiếm khuế dí chuyển.
Một số người đã cố hỏi liệu viên nhân cân bệnh có liên quan đến việc tiếp xúc lâu dài với xân 2 không.
Cô cho biết, giù có lối xống lạnh mạnh như thế nào, giương như cụ khó tránh khỏi số phật.
Kha Phi không có chự chứng só giảng của bệnh uống thư,
cô đi khám khi xuất hiện những cơn đau ở bụng giữa lạn từ hóa thử dân dài.
Cô đi vào trạm nghiệm của bản thân có thể kèng báo người trẻ chúi để xúc hỏi và đường bao giờ chú quan.
Theo giao dấu linh gian dàng từ bệnh việc chiếc dàng,
tì lệ mắt bệnh uống thư đại trực trang tăng hàng năm trong những năm gần đây và bệnh nhân ngày càng trẻ hơn.
Lỗi soại hiện là phục pháp phục biến và nhạc cảm nhất để phát hiện khối uống đau dù.